here now with reaction house oversight
committee chair James Comer house
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
house ways and means committee chairman
Jason Smith
um
Jim Jordan let me start with you
I smell a rat here and I suspect the
judge did as well so we're going to
believe that this critically important
point that this deal would ensure
there'd be no further prosecution for
Hunter Biden somehow they had a
misunderstanding on that point why do I
am not buying that for one second yeah
no this is now the fourth time that the
doj story has changed so David Weiss
said first he had all this Authority
then said well no I don't it's limited
to my Geographic my U.S attorney's
District then there was another letter
on July 10th of Lindsey Graham saying
well it's something different and now we
have this happen and remember son the
compelling thing that has happened in
the last several weeks is two Brave
whistleblowers coming forward chairman
Smith releasing their testimony publicly
and then them coming in front of Mr
Comer's oversight committee and
testifying and their credibility was
unimpeachable their story has been
consistent their facts have not wavered
their touch testimony has been
straightforward and has been validated
by an FBI agent who we've interviewed so
what I really want to do what the
Judiciary Committee really wants to do
is get into who are those people at this
now famous October 7th 2022 meeting
where David White said he had didn't
have authority to bring special to bring
the charges wherever we want ask for
special counsel designation and was
denied that by the justice department
and the justice department says
something different Mr shapley says this
is what David White said the justice
department said that's not what he said
we want to get to the other people in
that meeting Mr shapley Mr Weiss were in
that meeting and five other people were
there we want to talk to them and that's
what we'll be pursuing just as quickly
as we can and they took contemporaneous
notes at the time all right chairman
Smith let me go to you because what was
unfolding last night was beyond bizarre
and that is the document that you had
sent over talking about the
whistleblowers new evidence why the
judge should not go along with the
sweetheart plea deal and apparently a
woman from Hunter's Law Firm makes a
call to the clerk of the court and tries
to get your document removed the night
before it's going before the judge and
that didn't even get dealt with today
that that's exactly right Sean yesterday
morning we had our attorney file an
amicus brief before the court because we
wanted to make sure the judge had um the
testimony of the two IRS whistleblowers
that was before our committee had
credible information that needed to be
provided about an hour later
um a young lady called the court and
said that there was Private Social
Security information in our filing and
it needed to be taken down presented
themselves to be working for my attorney
my attorney noticed it within a short
period of time contacted the court
figured that out the judge actually
figured out by caller ID where this came
from and that was a law firm of Hunter
Biden's in New York and the judge
ordered those lawyers to contact to
respond to the court by nine o'clock
last night or face sanctions it's
absolutely
incredible that it would go to this
level let me tell you these are the same
attorneys Sean that the whistleblowers
testified saying that they heard these
attorneys tell prosecutors that if they
brought charges against the president's
son they would be facing career suicide
all right let me let me go to uh
Congressman chairman Comer so here the
the evidence that you have uncovered in
your Committee in your investigation
influence peddling schemes mirrored in
large part the evidence brought forth by
the IRS whistleblowers now the
whistleblowers were prevented from in
interviewing any of the Biden family
members the president maybe they could
make a case for everybody else I don't
think they should have been able to make
a case for they allow the statute of
limitations also to pass and then the
FBI is tipping off Hunter Biden and his
legal team on a very important issue
that they were going to have a surprise
visit and interview Hunter Biden explain
to me how this judge could actually go
along with this agreement with all of
that new information out there and
available
but she couldn't and the judge did the
right thing today was a victory for
justice in America if anyone was
watching The Whistleblower hearing that
we had in the oversight with the two
credible whistleblowers I mean they laid
out uh perfectly a series of crimes that
the president's son had committed it's
not just about tax evasion and the tax
evasion that they're getting around was
just for for two years for a W-2 it
didn't even include all the shell
company income that they've had that
that no one knows what what the
reasoning is behind the millions of
dollars they've received from foreign
Nationals it didn't include the foreign
agents registration act which is one of
the things that we said back in January
Jim Jordan I said was a clear law that
the president's son had committed you
also had the money laundering remember
six Banks filed reports with the with
the treasury Department that they
suspected this family was involved in
laundering money from state-owned
entities stayed on entity these are
foreign countries so the list goes on
and on and on it's obvious to anyone who
has any knowledge of the law that the
president's Sons committed a host of
crimes and all roads lead to Joe Biden
that's the other thing and that was I
think one of the most interesting things
from the testimony that Jason Smith got
in the transcript interview and we heard
in the hearing was they wanted to
interview Biden family members and they
felt pretty strongly that this was
directly linked to Joe Biden and so and
on Monday your committee will will take
a sworn deposition from Devin Archer the
former business partner of Hunter Biden
and we expect him to testify that on 24
two dozen occasions he can recall Joe
Biden being used by Hunter to call into
meetings with Farm business on Farm
business deals with the foreign business
partners the same Joe Biden that that
swore that he never once talked to us
son about his foreign business dealings
Congressman yes there's a lot of
speculation that that's what he's going
to say but remember one thing Jason
Smith pointed out these lawyers have
intimidated many of the witnesses that
we've tried to bring forward for
depositions and transcribed interviews
and they've told them things like you're
only going to implicate yourself we're
not going to get in trouble hopefully
the witnesses like Devin Archer and the
others who we're going to be bringing
before the committee this summer
hopefully they saw what happened in that
court today and that these lawyers
aren't going to continue to get away
with the shenanigans that they tried to
pull yesterday when they lied and said
they were part of ways and means staff
to get something removed those days are
over and we're in control of this thing
and I believe if these witnesses will
come forward and tell the truth I think
the American people are going to be in
for a big eye-opener with respect to Joe
Biden now a congressman Jordan your your
investigation in the Judiciary Committee
is running in tandem with with
Congressman Comer's investigation into
the the Biden family businesses and that
is the weaponization and and how the FBI
has been politicized weaponized the doj
has been politicized weaponized uh they
didn't even want to hear from the
whistleblowers and they're willing to
make that sweetheart deal I don't think
that's a deal that anybody else in
America would be able to get does this
now add to the long list of special
treatment the bidens have gotten well
yeah and the judge asked the fundamental
question she asked the prosecutor she
asked the folks from doj has this kind
of deal ever been put together before is
this unprecedented she asked has it ever
happened before and the prosecutor's
answer was know your honor that so it
hasn't he he responded back this is
complete this is why what what chairman
Comer said if this is truly a win for
equal application of the law which is a
Hallmark of this great country the
greatest country ever that's what we're
supposed to focus on and that was the
motivation of Gary shapley and Mr
Ziegler they came forward because they
saw unequal application of the law
that's why we want to talk to these
folks get all the facts and then move
forward from there and and chairman
Smith I'll ask you lastly here
um when the I what the IRS
whistleblowers that we've heard from and
those that are upcoming it seems that
they're going to contradict prosecutor
Weiss and and his contention that he
never said these things that he didn't
have the ability to bring cases in other
jurors
if this 567 maybe more whistleblowers
versus that one person who are you going
to believe
exactly Sean one important point is is
that the two IRS whistleblowers that's
came forward that testified in Jamie
Comer's committee their stories have
stayed the same the stories that have
not stayed the same are those of
prosecutor Weiss and also of the Biden
family that is the issue we have really
credible whistleblowers come forward and
they're all singing from the same tune
wow great job all three of you and uh
the the walls are caving in now on the
Biden family Syndicate that's for sure a
lot more coming in the days weeks months
ahead thank you all thanks all three of
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else